[Musique]
quand ce n'est pas la violence des gangs
c'est la corruption ou les troubles
politiques des problèmes évoqués par
Justin Trudeau pour dépeindre le
portrait de la situation en Haïti au
moment où il participait au sommet des
chefs de gouvernement de la Communauté
des Caraïbes il a alors annoncé de
l'aide supplémentaire notamment le
déploiement de deux navires de la Marine
royale canadienne qu'est-ce que ça va
changer pour nous en parler je joins
l'ambassadeur du Canada en Haïti
Sébastien carrière monsieur carrière
bonjour
monsieur carrière d'abord parlons des
navires ça c'est nouveau ils vont être
là pour surveiller quoi intercepter quoi
mais surtout est-ce que c'était de là va
contribuer à améliorer la situation à
votre avis
absolument alors c'est des navires de
surveillance là et de patrouille côtière
donc
leur mandat leur mission lequel qui
expliquait dans la communauté de presse
de défense nationale c'est de
patrouiller dans les autoritaires et ici
pour déranger les activités des gants on
sait que les gangs utilisent notamment
la [__] Port-au-Prince pour circuler
pour transporter
des mandégans des otages
la drogue la marchandise des armes
sortent des choses donc la présence
d'une avec Canadien va empêcher ses
activités là c'est aussi des navires qui
sont bien équipés pour faire la
surveillance côté donc un peu dans la
lignée de l'avion qui est passé il y a
deux semaines pour faire des opérations
de l'enseignement donc c'est pour
augmenter nos capacités et les capacités
de la Police nationale d'Haïti de bien
surveiller les mouvements des gangs de
mieux comprendre
le Canada soit à la tête d'un
déploiement militaire ou à la tête d'une
force d'intervention intern ationale
mais le Canada est réticent à cette
idée-là pensant que la solution doit
venir de l'intérieur monsieur carrière
est-ce que cette solution venant de
l'intérieur est en train de prendre
forme
je pense que oui moi je vois pas de
position nécessairement entre l'aide
étrangère et les solutions internes au
niveau sécuritaire en fait c'est
complémentaire donc nous on dit depuis
le début que la solution à long terme au
problème d'Haïti c'est la police
nationale
donc on a pris les deux chiffres livré
des blindés il y a eu deux livraisons
depuis le mois d'octobre une troisième
livraison dans les prochains jours et
une autre ensuite plus tard en février
de cette opération de surveillance du CP
140 Aurora qui a eu lieu il y a deux
semaines il y a un partage de
renseignement qui va suivre ça là il y a
les bateaux qui arrivent donc c'est
quand même des déplorer militaires de
façon significative donc je pense qu'on
peut on doit travailler avec la PNH et
non pas se substituer à la PNH et c'est
la preuve que choisir le Canada
concentration avec ses partenaires
notamment régionaux donc la stratégie
canadienne il y a aussi l'aspect des
sanctions donc d'ailleurs juste un
Trudeau a annoncé des nouvelles
sanctions contre deux membres de l'élite
haïtienne à quel point ces sanctions là
ont un poids est-ce que suffisamment de
pays qui les appliquent pour qu'elle
soit efficace
les sanctions ont un impact très
important je pense qu'il faut regarder
en premier lieu l'impact en Haïti
des sanctions canadiennes par exemple
les banques haïtiennes on va appliqué
les sanctions canadiennes on liquidé les
actifs des personnes visées par les
fonctions canadiennes pour préserver
leur relation d'affaires avec les
banques canadiennes c'est un exemple il
y a aussi des sanctions secteurs
politiques qui ont eu un effet politique
important il faut au niveau des
partenaires intentions nous on encourage
des partenaires américains européens et
autres à faire plus il y a les fonctions
des Nations Unies qui sont en train
d'être préparées comme tiers d'experts
qui étaient nommé dans les mois qui
viennent de passer la comité fait son
travail maintenant il y aura des
recommandations qui seront faites
ensuite au Conseil de sécurité donc ça
ça avance au niveau des Nations Unies
quand les nations c'est essentiellement
tous les pays du monde
les Américains ont aussi annoncé
que il y a d'autres sanctions au niveau
de des interdictions de visa qui ont été
qui ont été appliquées cette semaine
donc les partenaires avancent aussi le
Canada monte la voie puis on encourage
tout le monde écoutez nous on montre la
voir on encouragement d'aller le plus
vite possible mais on comprend que
chacun a sa législation chacun sa
réglementation c'est des enjeux
extrêmement compliqués donc on va
respecter les rythmes les façons de
faire tout un chacun vous êtes
ambassadeur en Haïti vous voyez que
votre mission prend quelle forme
maintenant à la suite de ce sommet des
Caraïbes puis est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est possible de voir le retour de la
sécurité en Haïti d'ici la fin de votre
mandat
écoutez ce qui est surtout important
c'est pas c'est pas mon mandat ou ça
durée mais c'est la sécurité du peuple
ici donc on a une population qui vit
dans les ondes de nos droits en état de
siège terrorisé par les chefs de gang il
y a des meurtres il y a des viols à
répétition souvent donc cette population
là a besoin de sécurité droit à une
certaine sécurité
il y a de la kidnapping aussi dans
toutes les régions notamment de
Port-au-Prince mais ailleurs aussi qui a
repris beaucoup depuis quelques semaines
donc ce qui est important c'est que les
locataires les autres partenaires
internationaux mais tout en oeuvre pour
accompagner la PNH de façon robuste pour
permettre à la PNH de rétablir la
sécurité c'est un travail difficile ce
travail de longue haleine moi je j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour les policiers
et les policières haïtiens haïtiennes
qui font ce travail demande beaucoup de
courage et brésilien beaucoup auraient
aband le contenu donc je pense que c'est
de la responsabilité de les appuyer de
façon très robuste et le plus rapidement
possible
merci